How do we get our customers and
suppliers to buy into
our WHY?
To buy into our -
How to - how do I get somebody that
I went on a date with to fall in
love with me?
It's like.
You you're asking the wrong
question.
You have to be clear
and open about what you stand for.
And just like when you hire
somebody, you want
to make sure that when you hire
them, that they share your values,
that they believe in your vision.
You know, they don't just think it's
corny, you know, or
marketing, but rather
that they buy into it.
And sometimes we'll make mistakes.
And sometimes people will come and
they fall in love with it after the
fact.
But it's, you know, we try on
balance to bring people that we
believe will get along
with the people who work here
because of our values and our cause.
And so too, is it with with
suppliers.
I think that
or clients are it's
the same thing, which is we stand
for what we stand for and our goal
is to attract people who believe
what we believe.
The more vocal we are about
what we believe those people
literally will come to us
or turn down a competitor,
who may even be cheaper, because
they would rather do business with
us.
And so it's OK
to do business with a supplier that
doesn't believe what we believe, but
we have to go in with eyes open
knowing full well that this is just
a transaction.
You offer a decent product.
You give me a decent price.
This is not going to be a lifelong
relationship.
This is a
transactional relationship.
And when it's done, I'm
just going to hold you to very
different
standards, right?
Because when it's transactional,
we're a little less patient when
things go wrong
and sometimes we you just can't do
that too often.
It's like if you're
living a healthy lifestyle, you can
have chocolate cake and just not too
often.
So, yeah, I think the more vocal you
are, the more you attract and then
you have to make decisions like
you're hiring people because they're
going to become a member of your
family as well.
This is the
difference between
the short-term, finite minded
and the long-term infinite minded,
the finite-minded.
Is it the cheapest today?
Is it the best relationship today?
And pay no attention to the
secondary or tertiary effects
and definitely pay no attention to
what will happen in five years.
Whereas that long-term minded,
infinite-minded player
looks at its looks
at something and looks at someone
and says, "Well, you know you're not
the cheapest, but I think we're
going to get along just fine."
And over the course of time,
the quality of work will
far outweigh whatever you paid.
A friend of mine who's a consultant
loves to joke about her clients
that they never have the time or
money to do it right the first time,
but they always have the time and
money to do it again.
And I think when you're
infinite-minded, you consider those
factors from the from the beginning.